ce qui s'est passé sur la place ce jour
là vous aviez vous voulez y penser
qu'est ce que vous a dit que vous alliez
passer de cellule en cellule pour
éliminer des terroristes pour commencer
[Musique]
je veux savoir sur ce mec est un
guerrier le meilleur que juillet
est arrivée des merdes alors tu peux tu
es tu terroriste vilata chose qui compte
c'est la mission pas vous voilà comment
on est quand un petit correctement il
était déjà du conte particulier un mot
jamais devenir une affaire personnelle
[Musique]
il ya un jour 15 kilos de plutonium au
vif par quoi il en a prévenu le
personnel monsieur train de faire c'est
moi qui lui ai appris le respect pour
les sites web en verre
du coup
aussi d'une ferrand soit pour toi non
c'est que le dit pas